today we're chatting with Nicole Alonso
and the Oklahoma Ward they're out in
Tulsa Oklahoma they're the filmmakers
behind the upcoming film crawl
crawl I don't know I wait did I say the
right crawl crawl no I almost
think this a crawl you know
just like which way to go with it and
you go coming from a man that never
swears yeah funny doing on like I really
swear see you guys really shouldn't have
titles like that you see what you guys
are doing to me yeah you should see us
out if we're at a coffee shop and we
meet somebody and they're like so what
do you do and we're like well we just
made a film and they like oh yeah what's
the name of it it's like hmm oh it's
same reaction every time I mean from art
from our perspective I mean the fact
that you switch titles from the original
crawl and now you've added these couple
extra words there I mean it it grabs
your attention you know and we just
spoke to a guy Adam Leipzig who is a
former executive at Disney and he's like
one thing that he can't stand with
independent film or not that he can't
stand but one thing that he says we have
to get a lot better with is just coming
up with better titles so you know we
think that's great yeah it's uh it's not
you know the way that it happened was an
accident which uh you know we found out
we went into a panic mode here because
there is another film we submitted to a
film festival and they wrote us back and
actually reprimanded us by saying we it
clearly states we only take premieres
and you had been to 12 film festivals
what are you doing submitting us and we
were like we have no idea what you're
talking about and come to find out
there's another independent film then
crawl uh whom has we knew about it but
it came out like a year and a half ago
but they're still on the film bed
they're still trying to get more film
festivals
and we didn't think they would still be
doing that so we knew it our mission
consultant peter broderick was like look
this is a problem you have to change the
title because other film festivals won't
contact you they'll just throw you in
the bin thinkin you're that film and um
so you know we we we took it online and
talk to all the people and we came up
with 10 titles that we thought were
great and everybody kept sending nobody
would say publicly except for Donnie
hall uh and gary king came out was like
me you guys got to do that and we were
like oh yeah it's a funny joke yeah yeah
and then all of a sudden literally we
would be getting five to ten emails and
night going man you guys that would be
ballsy it's great it's perfect and uh
because we then did a little test on our
own offline with people and we realized
people were like I would watch that just
to see what it is and uh and on our
peter broderick isn't very
straight-laced you know he went to Yale
he wears a sweater you know he's always
very you know it's amazing that he's got
this love for gritty independent films
but it just does say no like when we
skyping he's got a hundred thousand
books behind him when he's a lawyer an
old cousin and we were like up Peter um
where we were thinking about crawl
crawl he was like I love it you gotta do
that really we were like okay don't go
hey it was a calculated masterminding
point on our end but it was and it was
actually one of those things that I
think that we both learned over this
process which is just because you lay
out these plans you still got to keep
your your mind open to change with the
edit with the test audiences um with
your your PR of the Moody if you see
it's not working and you go but we think
it really works and it's not you know
every change that we've made we never
were
no has only helped us so at some point
water awesome yeah and I'll be going now
that we're now that we're recording
everything we just want to say we you
know we sweet we just we love that you
can we love their love that you keep in
sort of the food of the the character in
style and that's awesome I don't have
much choice because it's you know they
grow out takes forever but i like it so
i thought i'd keep it for a while just
have fun with it if we end up doing
anything yeah there's a little secret
okay yeah nevermind well we're going to
talk to quicken the project looking it
being funded this time that might
require her to have the same haircut yes
oh sure there but it's beds that's you
know it's still way a lot of negotiation
a lot of lawyers and all that kind of
stuff but we're excited we're very
excited it's nice to uncover the little
tidbits there get to the secrets you
know it you guys hear it here first ya
know and that's what we're looking to do
here you know you know as well as we're
releasing goodbye promise we're just
trying to create some very conduct very
candid conversation it sort of helps us
document the process as we sort of move
forward from from from day to day and
then were able to put this stuff online
and and and essentially these kind of
conversations become our story you know
as we sort of take on this very
ambitious release and and one thing you
brought up there Oklahoma is submitting
um crawl crawl crawl to film
festivals and and we want we want to
just kind of here where you guys stand
on that you know because on our end you
know we decided you know well over a
year ago like you know what we're just
not going to do the film festival Rob
you know you know we were just more
determined about bringing the work doing
our best to try to figure out a way
where we can just go directly to the
audience online and you guys as we
understand it are waiting on film
supposing we just want to hear your
mindset in terms of what you're looking
to do with crawl crawl well I'll
say a couple things and then i'll let
you get your opinion on it because you
as an actor and everything will
definitely have a different than you
know i'm sure uh you know first of all i
think what you all are doing this
brilliant i really really do in fact I
think he's so brilliant here's real
honesty I was less of it I was like that
i was like i love it i think it's a
perfect way to use a platform like
IndieGoGo I just think it's brilliant um
and I nicely think you guys have a
really good shot at really creating a
new way of filmmakers to look at
distribution because look are we knew
when we did this film um we have one
goal and our goal is to make the best
film we could on our ten thousand dollar
budget find more money so that we could
do a better project and we know that the
only way that that will happen is to get
an audience I think that's the hardest
thing in the world you know 10,000
people isn't an audience you know you
need to be able to get to 50,000 people
uh if you're going to do an independent
and make some money and then be able to
rely on those people so I didn't want to
do film festivals I I even told my
distribution consultant I'm not
interested in them I hope this doesn't
hurt me I don't care about them I love
going to them I love seeing films in
them but it's not what's important to me
um but my distribution consultant then
reminded me that it is and uh it's very
important um for us after we passed his
text in other words he wanted us to do
the test audiences and realistically
look at
how good the film was as far as getting
it out there on traditional marketing
platforms and for instance our last film
was not good enough he was like you're
wasting your time going to film
festivals you should just figure out a
way to get as much attention as you can
put it out there online we he was like
let's test chrome crawl and see if
audiences really respond he was talking
between 90 and a hundred percent of
people that uh good scores luckily we
did Oh congratulations you well I mean
you know we've yeah I am very proud of
that that was the first test he then
said he didn't he then shared with us he
said look you know here's the thing
you're right on that edge you have
something that you could make a lot of
money on and get attention on the no
guarantee but if you find the right film
festival he's actually having us turned
down film festivals and we've been doing
that and it's the scariest thing on the
planet okay I'm scary because to fold
one up our last film we couldn't get in
the Kansas City cornfield film festival
I mean it literally had 14 rejection
letters now I I understand of our
distribution consultant has a film that
I've seen that's very good he's been
turned down by all the top film
festivals and it's a great film so you
know there's that you've got to talk to
yourself because you know you get into
this am i any good why is nobody taking
this why why is it not going you
anywhere you question yourself and then
you wake up in the morning and you keep
pushing on and I've learned that though
vegetables are can make that down spiral
a more profound because you know when
you start getting rejection letters from
film festivals it's you know I don't
care who you are it's not fun but so
when
we got these film festivals coming back
to us going yes we'd love to do this we
were we were jumping up and down we were
high five when we were like somebody
likes us we got hold of our distribution
consultant and he was like no you can't
you can't tell them tell them no thank
you and first of all I didn't want to
offend them uh because they liked our
film um but what we learned is that your
premiere is the most important part of a
film festival wrap you only have one
premiere and if you start at a film
festival that a lot of press and a lot
of Industry people will not be at you're
ruining your premier status because a
lot of these help vegetables will only
take your film if it's a premier so it
creates them it creates a time problem
it creates a if I turn these people down
and I don't get in this film festival
over here what have I done now I have no
film festivals um so you know it's a
very scary time for us but at the same
time very exciting we have a lot of
trust I know that our distribution
consultant I would never tell us he's
been one hundred percent honest with us
and he feels strongly that one of the
six that he wants us to premiere at UH
will get us in um but I'm not gonna lie
to you we sit here every day and check
the email box because uh turning down a
film festival you take the chance of
that film festival going will never
accept this person again although I will
throw them in there real quickly so far
they understand they understand it when
you like look I thought I was going to
get in this film festival where I could
sell it to make some money on this and I
didn't get in so I'm gonna have to
bypass you because I'm trying to get in
this one and they only take premieres so
that's that's where we're at ah I can't
give you much more than that because I
haven't been in one to go
see if it's really worth it our
distribution consultant seems to think
so I mean I don't know how you feel
about them you know I I just want people
to see the movie so to me it's like I'd
love to get in because then you know
people would see it I don't know like I
don't I've always kind of looked at film
festivals as a way friend indie films to
do that um but I know that things are
changing and so really I'm just like I
just wanted to get to an audience so
however that happens with me is fine as
the actor i mean i don't i guess i guess
in a sense we're stuck in what you all
always talked about in and and the
guests that you have and even stop that
David and I talked about is it is
changing but somehow that old system is
still there and it's still profitable
and it's still a way to do it but I
think it comes down to do they think the
film whether they think it's good or not
do they think the film will fit into
that industry and if it if they think it
might we can't risk making three hundred
thousand verses making thirty thousand
you know if it was a
twenty-thousand-dollar risk if he was
like look you can go on itunes and in a
month you could make fifty sixty
thousand and gain an audience of 20,000
people or you could get into this
prestigious Film Festival and you're
looking at a deal at three hundred to a
half million well that's a life changer
for a Nicole and I I mean that's and we
go okay what six months we can we can
try we may still not get in but he seems
to think we have a shot at the audience
seemed to respond well to it so you know
we were stuck with well let's give it
six months and it doesn't work then
we're going to do an alternate route you
know how far into the six months are you
know like is this six months from today
or is this six months from from a couple
months ago we should know all our
answers by January so no
it's automatic so then you know then
you'll wait for for the Sun so obviously
one of these festivals you're applying
to a Sun Dance OH so the aim is it is
one of them is maybe the next program
anything you know what yeah I'm not
allowed to say I'm night all right you
don't have to say but it might be a good
guess mom but there's like to film
festivals that have been there around
that area around the same exact time
maybe across the street I mean yeah
there's not generally some cold
vegetables ah you know Mom but uh you
know we have to be at the same dilemma
you know cuz I'm you know that was a
thing it's like dude do we keep waiting
for this next festival deadline you know
we we thought about submitting to
Tribeca we thought about admitting we
thought about submitting to AFI and then
even before even before this online
release because you know I mean I'm film
festival like LA Film Fest we know we
would have no chance of getting into
that one and people also talked about
Toronto as may be trying Toronto and and
we had a producer that looked at the
film he's the producer of The Godfather
and lost in translation he's like you
guys should really consider AFI and and
so we have to sort of think about that
for a little bit before launching this
this online campaign you know it's
really hard to say because there's so
many factors that go into it we know at
the end of the day we have we have this
film that we made that had no production
budget you know we sort of piece it
together we know it's rough around the
edges we also know it has a lot of heart
to it we know it's affecting a lot of
people but in terms of where does that
fit in on the on the festival scale you
know on our end we just didn't want to
play the waiting game especially since
it took us three years to get to this
point so you know another six months
it's just like people want to see the
film give it to the people yeah i mean
look look uh we being a spoke on the
phone five or six months ago you know
which is we both talked about that this
this this is to me the hardest part of
the process because it is awaiting him
and i feel uncomfortable i'm not going
to mention this person's name but we
just spoke to a filmmaker um
who submitted to a couple of film
festivals didn't get in them and so I
had to wait a year for the next for the
ones that he felt was important to get
into to premiere he had a whole year him
to sit on that project for another year
and I go you know that is that is the
process that i really hope in the next
four or five years platforms like what
you're doing and other platforms can
really force these film festivals to
make the process a little faster because
it's uh you know this is it it's it's a
horrible time I believe because it's it
is just sitting here waiting and it's it
in the gamble is you don't even know if
it's going to work you don't even know
if you're going to get in so you know we
could wait six months and look we
legitimately could not get in any of
these film festivals it has no bearing
on you know our distribution consultant
was so candid with us he was like look
some years they just decide we don't
want we only want films that make people
feel good or we only want political
films and it doesn't matter how good
your film is there's a very good shot
that if it doesn't fit into their format
that year you're not getting it so you
know uh I don't think we would wait a
year I don't think you know when he told
us that I was like no I don't think
wicked I don't think mentally our
creative spirit could do it because this
is a crushing time it's it's rejection
it's waiting it's are we going to fall
flat is it just going to disappear uh
you know and so you search for stuff
every day to try and fill up your time
because I don't know for you all how it
is starting to work on another project
while you're still watching over this
baby infant that you have that you're
trying to show the world it's it's it's
you know it's we talk about other
projects we write some we have ideas but
we're like you know we still have to
keep focused on this but
there's like seven days that will pass
and we're just like well there's nothing
we can do we can't we can't put out any
more footage Christ will have the whole
movie out okay put more photo great you
know what check out our teaser trailer
again you know like uh it's difficult
it's difficult but I respect what you
guys did I mean uh I will probably have
more of a feeling or answer to what you
originally asked once I'm through this
process yeah you know for us we're just
happy that it's it's sort of out there
in the world I mean it's been three
years and it's been weighing on our
shoulders and so I think right now we're
still in this phase where it's just nice
to have it out there in the world we
felt this sense of responsibility but we
did go through it calling theaters you
know and a lot of theaters didn't get
back to us um and sending it out and
waiting and waiting I mean we're lucky
that you know we're doing film courage
on the side so we have that to kind of
occupy our time and as a distraction but
I'm sure it would be really tough and
especially to it's like you owe money on
something about the film and that's that
whole thing and you want to just like
get that monkey off your back and yeah
and deal with that I'm sure that's got
to be really stressful yeah it's you
know I mean thinking I mean our bill I
mean you guys have you guys had no
budget I think we had 10,000 by the time
we were done and we don't really hold
that money to anybody right now I mean
you know it was our money we don't have
it we're broke you know so we like to
try and get that back but I do think
that allows us to do things like what
you're doing because you know what I'm
saying it's not like we have an investor
with a million-dollar sitting over our
shoulder going I want that million back
and then plus i get the next million and
then you can start making some money and
you know because that would be
terrifying at the moment ah and we we
just spoke with filmmaker whom has that
concern you know his concern is making
sure this person gets their money back
so that they can use them again and move
on right now we have a little bit of
freedom we could we could anyway
we're going to go a different route
until we got those audience test
screenings and we were literally stunned
and so we thought well maybe we do have
something here and it's worth six months
if the audience test screenings would
have been 50 50 I think we'd be doing
something exactly like what you're doing
uh figuring out some way to get it out
there in the world and create some
talking and create some energy behind it
take what money we made and move on to
make the next fellow so you know but
it's got to be killing you guys I mean
when I mean do you all when you made the
decision I mean what I mean do you
question it ever idea i remember hehe
told me about it was like I don't know
close to midnight or something and I'm
like hmm and and when I heard was like a
million-dollar mark that's what scared
me and then you originally ones doing on
Kickstarter and I said well not
Kickstarter I said I think IndieGoGo
because a million dollars i mean what's
what are the chances of that that's so
did we questioned it yeah I mean we
questioned film courage all the time we
question everything i mean it's it's not
easy any of this and and we have to kind
of go back to like why we do it and that
is what we love to hear other people's
stories and we love to put up really
cool content and I think that keeps us
coming back to a lot of this stuff and
this is kind of an experiment so we're
not really trying to think about the
dollar amount I mean yeah I be great to
wake up and be like oh cool there's X
amount of dollars in the account you
know and maybe we don't have to work for
a month or something but um I think it's
just more about like trying it as an
experiment and growing something because
I think that's what we determined was
our was our main purpose with film
courage we like to watch stuff kind of
grow it's it's really cool you know yeah
yeah and if i can add to that I mean you
know you have to be a complete lunatic
to say that okay we're good we're gonna
set a million-dollar goal and we're
gonna just give our fun way for a dollar
and expect to come anywhere near that so
you know obviously you know I
and I had this idea in mind it was
inspired last summer I was um you know
one of the day jobs I had this past
summer was as a caregiver um you know
and I haven't talked about the story yes
I'm sharing with you guys first but um
you know I was a caregiver for a
gentleman that's in his 70s he's he's
he's all set for the rest of his life in
terms of his financial position and I'm
dumb and he was recovering from back
surgery and so he was very groggy very
sleepy need a lot of attention and so
you know when he would sleep I would
read the book that the outcome is I
don't you guys have read that but it's
just this wonderful tale of this young
shepherd boy who has like this this
grand dream of he just has this grand
dream and any base he has this quest is
this long quest of going after this and
basically this impossible dream that he
has and so I was reading that book and I
was this and I was also thinking about
like we're getting closer closer to
finishing the film I'm like how do we
how do we release this film so it was
just it was like this whole thing
turning together and I started churning
with this idea about a year ago and it
was a really weird dynamic for me
because here I am I'm like I'm staring
every day at a guy that's in his 70s
that has everything he you know
everything he needs in life he has you
know in terms of his whole living
condition um and here i am just just
looking at him thinking like you know am
I ever going to get to that point I have
everything I need around me I mean of
course he wants his health he wants to
to be back on his feet so that that was
what he was dealing with but it's just
like you know you put so much energy and
send the kind of stuff that we're doing
you know and so you know I've seen I've
seen a lot of death in the last last
couple years you know we've seen a lot
of people come and go about a lot of
people close to us we've had our our
pets die and it's just like you know as
independent filmmakers we don't get a
lot of chances to just go out and just
do something crazy so I so I feel like a
lunatic to say okay this is what we're
gonna do
because there's no way you can pitch
anyone that idea and have them think
that you're saying but at the same time
you have in your where you want to wake
up and have like me something and go
after something you know and I know it
doesn't need anything to the world but
it's just like you know what I'd rather
wake up every day put my energy into
something and at least feel like I'm
going after something so right now it
feels good it feels good to to get less
sleep to have a purpose and even if we
you know you know another thing about
setting the goal is just like especially
in indy gogo is like it doesn't matter
what we end up with you know because at
least we get to fight every day and
that's the great thing about that so
yeah those are some of the story those
are some of my thoughts and that's
interesting and how you can put that
because normally for a campaign it to us
it's something we don't enjoy doing
because it's it's you know it's it's you
want to do this project and can you
raise the money because you want to do
the project so it's stressful and you've
got to work at it every single day and
and you just want to go I just want to
go make my project oh you know and and
you know it's a lot of work it's
interesting because what you're saying
you enjoyed this part of it I guess it's
because your goal is not to hit a
million dollars your goal is to get it
out there see what you can do see see
what kind of energy you can create with
it which again I I think it's a great
idea I really I really do because in my
crazy mind when I saw it I went you just
became Lionsgate IndieGoGo is now
Lionsgate people go and pay money to see
your movie and they're not going to a
movie theater they're not going through
Lionsgate they're not going to redbox
they're going through indiegogo and it's
perfect and i agree with you King
starter would not have been the way I
because look if you have 30,000 people
that come through the want to see
offense great I mean that's perfect and
you read the benefits plus you gain an
audience plus people talk about it I
just think it's great I think you kind
of turn their fundraising campaign into
a distributor and that's why I'm hoping
it works
is I think it's a brilliant idea yeah no
that's the way we that's the way we
looked at it you know because honestly
when you look at you know when you look
at our options i mean you know listen to
what you guys are saying it's just like
I mean it almost it almost sucks big and
independent filmmaker I hate to say that
but it's just like you know as we are
looking at our options honestly it's
like look at what film festivals you
know it's so frustrating in terms of the
weight that you guys are talking about
like I have to wait six months you know
like so like you said you're you're
turning out the you know the same
screenshots the same video and you know
setting you know it's just like you're
not able to sort of you know it empower
your audience to get behind your efforts
and it really do something that really
needs something so and the whole thing
with you know this film fest was little
waiting game not not knowing whether
you're going to get in all right and
then there's a whole sort of like
there's a whole bunch of things in terms
of when you actually do get in you know
just because you get into a film
festival doesn't know it guarantees like
a prime slot you know you might get into
your your premier still could be like
ten in the morning you know and and you
can still have just a couple people in
the audience so you could be all geared
up but there's a lot of money in terms
of the submission fee I mean that's
minor but but then in terms of traveling
to the film festival investing that full
week promoting your film trying to get
people to buy tickets and then when they
do that money doesn't go in your pockets
it goes into the box of the film
festival so you know and then on top of
that you might not be allowed to sell
dvds and things like that some festivals
like don't want you doing that sort of
stuff so it's not really conducive to
the filmmaker so for us that that option
was really frustrating for us and then
on the traditional distribution side
it's like you're going to turn your film
over did you want to jump nah I was just
thinking like to if you wanted it for
wallet at a theater a week run is going
to be thousands of dollars and yeah
maybe they'll take it because you're
gonna give them that money who's to say
you're going to get seats in there
especially if it's not your hometown you
know and and we called around and they
were just great theaters in awesome
parts of the country we're like oh how
cool would it be the screen here and
it's like 6 grand for a week and there's
no chance we'd ever make that money back
no chance so it's just like
yeah we really prestigious and it would
stroke the ego to have it screen there
but it's it's going to be a money loser
yeah that's what I was trying to say
which is when I when I when I told our
consultant we know I don't care about
film festivals that's what I'm talking
about I there I I don't know if I'm I
don't know why I'm this way but it
doesn't mean a damn thing to me if a
film has those in Sigma's on it or best
of it just doesn't mean anything to me I
don't pick movies out to watch because
of that I don't feel like I accomplished
anything because of that are our when I
sat down with my consultant we looked at
the same thing you guys are talking
about I mean it's the same thing as fast
as everything is changing and that's
what's frustrating I know what's going
to happen but it's still it's not there
you know it's not it's not like we can
call up rent box ourselves and say hey
look let's put this on redbox and they
go yeah look you can log online put it
up yourself and you know late we're not
there yet so what do we have the same
things you just talked about I mean
that's it except for what you all are
doing I find that fascinating um but I
know it's it's uh I you know I we told
her right up front we had two goals we
want to we want to reach an audience and
what's our best chance at reaching the
largest audience and we would like to
start our careers meaning we can't I
don't even know we just five as a couple
going through another 20 years of not
ever having a dollar not being able to
do anything uh and accept this which we
love doing but we're like you know we
put we the same thing you were talking
about you know it's like our are we ever
going to be able to pay the electric
bill like do we always have to have
stuff cutoff like um and so you know you
begin to go how do we start making some
money well I neither one of us
I'll say me I know you love shoes but
neither one of us care about being rich
and I know it sounds like a stupid thing
to say we would love to be rich but only
because it would allow us to do a whole
bunch of projects but we go we've got to
be able to eke out a living at this
because it's uh it's insane it is
insanity to wake up every morning and go
I've made a movie now how do I get a
hundred people to see this and what do I
have to do and oh it's gonna I gotta pay
to me that's what it upsets me about the
theaters it's like what I've gotta pay
for people to come see it hell I'd
rather go online and say I'll pay
everybody two bucks to watch my movie
what you know is it just the well it was
in a theater and I think a lot of people
want that I think that makes a lot of
people feel good I I would be terrified
I'd be going how are we going to get why
we're gonna fill up this theater for a
week in Idaho we don't know anybody how
we gonna do that because what we're
competing with look everybody laughs and
jokes about all the campaign trailers
that Hollywood does we see broke now we
see trailers for trailers we're
competing with people who have a movie
also but have millions of dollars to
motivate people to go out and interact
with that film we don't have any way to
reach that many people to motivate them
to get involved with our stories so we
have to do it one person by one person
hi how you doing thank you for liking it
and then you create a relationship it's
it's uh it's still it's very it's very
frustrating i know it's different for
you because you can go off and make
other films yeah indian films i'm also
invested in crow pro because it's
not like i just showed up acted and
walked off like I've been pretty
invested in it from the beginning so
right I want to see it succeed just as
much as you because it kind of feels
like my baby I mean I know
you wrote it and you're no no wait I
sold you go that way and I'm really
proud of it so I really do want people
to see it so i can still definitely
relate to well how you know just what
what David had asked how did you feel
before we spoke with Peter about should
we have gone film festivals should we
have skipped film festivals should we
have gone maybe just straight to video
on demand and and jumped in that arena
or did you want the oval festivals I
kind of had thought film festivals I was
a little nervous because of our
experience last time with film festivals
but I felt like this film was better um
as far as you know what I mean I like
you know what I mean but I felt like we
had a shot at film festivals this time
so I I was kind of hoping for it but if
Peter had said you know that's not the
fastest way to an audience or that's not
going to guarantee you an audience I
would have been like find whatever I
just want to get to an audience so I
when I was kind of excited when he was
like I think we should start there
because I just think that'll be a fun
experience anyways like yeah I got to
tell you that did you guys do up did you
guys do any type of test audience at all
did you like a screening or for like a
handful of people that we trusted we
trusted them to give us honest feedback
but not like like low blow like we
wanted people that were going to be
constructive with it so we did yeah yeah
why I got to tell you for us I think I
think literally what has kept both of us
going in our energy high is sitting
through those three audiences and
experiencing what did you really like to
see strangers interact with your film I
i literally would tell any filmmaker to
do that for the rest of my life even if
they threw all the comments away the
energy that we have to go it was almost
better than sex it was it was
unbelievable it was we both looked like
three year olds at Christmas we were
like just the energy the nerves and then
watching the audience like high-five
each other and every
we were like I want this again and if I
have to wait eight months to get there
to sit in front of an audience to see
this it's worth it if we hadn't had that
right now i think i'd still be drunk I
think I I literally I don't know what
I'd be doing it it's this is a horrible
horrible time I think for filmmakers I
think it's just because you know you
write the film and you've got all these
positive creative energies than you film
the film and you've got all this
creative people around you and everybody
believes in it then afterwards all the
hopes are high and then smack nothing
there's nothing creative going on it's
in everybody else's hands it's if you're
just sitting there going what do i do
what can I do because we both like to
tackle something if there's a problem we
want to get in there and be like okay
what do we do to fix it what would come
in we can't do anything I can't call it
the film festivals and go hey but you
need some help watching films like to me
what's going on help if we think you
should do this one and slide ours right
yeah it's it's just I feel for uh I know
horses again that's the thing I you know
I gotta give props to David Baker on
this he is his his spot on on the fact
that that's what youtubers get to
experience that we don't they get that
immediate response they make something
they put it out and within days they've
got all these people liking it hating it
bitching about it loving it sharing it
so they get that kind of feeling we get
that feeling like what once every two
and a half years you know you make the
movie you go the oprah and then you
gotta sit in Hopton an audience shows up
you know i don't know why we do this
it's the most insane it's like hitting
your head against the wall on going i
love this i love it it's crazy yeah you
know and i don't want to like totally
bathroom festivals I mean that the stuff
that you guys are talking about you know
certainly you know that that's you know
that's a big you know being with the
audience meeting people you know you
might meet like other cast and crew that
you might work with down the line so
there's a lot of benefits to that so
we're not
we trying to take away from from every
aspect of that but you know in terms of
youtube we just hosted a panel yesterday
I'm at Holly shorts of it was called
YouTube dominations you want to share
any thoughts on that Karen oh god oh I
want to know I want to do the sheriff oh
yeah just told Reuters I think we just
talked to like it was at five youtubers
and they're all like they all had
different types of channels um and just
how they got started and just you know
how many hours a day they put in and all
sorts of stuff so it was it was really
cool I mean some of them I think are
making a living off of it through like
Adsense and product placement stuff like
that we didn't want to delve in too much
to that he says that sort of their
personal finances but um you know just
just finding out about sort of what it
takes and it was interesting we we could
have gone another hour I think talking
about it but yeah yeah that's what we're
seeing with with this YouTube generation
you know is they're spending you know
instead of spending three years working
on one film they're they're spending
three years every week putting up
content on YouTube and they're in there
grandad audience with that content and
um you know they're just sharpening
their skill set every week and yeah you
know a lot of you know some of them are
making six figures some of them are
making then I think they said teacher
salaries or things like that i'm going
to me yeah but yeah I don't teach you
some right and then oh so here we are
we're caught between a queer caught
between the studio's who have the
megabucks that have the mega millions to
roll out the films that way and it's
really hard for us to compete in that
space and then the other of the spectrum
you have these these youtubers who maybe
they don't have the polish filmmaking
skills or you know skill set but they
have the audience you know and then we
find ourselves kind of like in between
those two worlds where you know maybe we
have some of the skill set that the
professionals have but we don't have the
audience that the youtubers have well
not only that to one of the girls on
America yawns she's on was Stanley's so
was it weren't heroes she's done comedy
but she has one web series that she's a
part of that has
millions of views and like half a
million subscribers and um she was
saying I think that she submitted a
video to some person and they said you
know what it's great but it needs to
actually be more gritty people like to
discover it so it looks like viral and
it looks kind of almost like a home
video so that was interesting about
YouTube videos that they almost like
them to be a little more like shaky
camera and just sort of focused on up
yeah I you know I'll back that up in it
I used to follow somebody and it was
really fun following their channel and
then you can tell they got a lot of
money that became very production level
and it kind of lost its spark it kind of
lost what drew me to it you know I felt
like a kitten is his basement doing this
and it was really good and then all of a
sudden after two years you can tell they
were making money it was a studio when
it became awesome it and it yeah it was
something but you know look i agree with
you David I do but and for me personally
I go I don't want to do YouTube videos
and that's not me putting them down
because I follow up what was it red
William Johnson I mean you know every
week I'm there I I I spent a lot of my
time on YouTube I still love to tell a
story in the long form content I still I
don't know if it's because I grew up uh
you know with films like The Godfather
and stuff like that um but I still
consider that in art and I and I do feel
privileged that I do get to try to do
that um I'm that I thought because I
know you guys were probably heard about
what David's doing with the city of sin
thing great project and i think i'm
going to be lucky enough to be able to
maybe do one of one of the stories and i
would do that and i would love it and I
put everything into it but I also went
that's not what I want to do you know I
don't want to tell um stories in that
format I still love making a movie and
if I have to make one
every five years that's fine with me ah
it does get frustrating i do because i
have so many stories i want to try and
tell i still really feel privileged and
I and I know this sounds all screwy and
hokey and but uh I do feel that the
reason it's so hard is sometimes because
it really is you've really got to be
good to hit a mass audience at it and I
like that challenge of it and I'm the
first one that can say I thought
isolation was the next clockwork orange
and when I stepped back at it and looked
at it I was like this has bunch of
problems but that fueled my fire to go
okay let me let me do it again and I see
what I've done and I go I still probably
got another year before I'm going to be
in a position to start on the next one
but I can't wait to get to the next one
and if somebody gave me the opportunity
right now and said right now I could if
you would do a youtube channel just for
two years you can build up the million
people I would probably turn it down I
mean that's not saying that I think that
film is more important than YouTube it's
just I love I love movies I love the
long for movies so I have to remind
myself why I'm doing this and it's
frustrating and it's tough and it's hard
and we may never make a dime at it but
as hard as it is I still have this weird
pride of like I'm doing what Paul Thomas
Anderson is doing the difference is I
don't have the budget that he has I
don't have a hundred people working
behind me but I'm still made a movie and
I could sit in a room with him and look
him right in the eye and I think he's
one of the best director as ever and I
I'd have no problem talking shop with
him none whatsoever because I feel like
I'm in that business I just
I don't have a studio behind me and I
don't have a large audience and he's got
a larger bank account than me but when
it comes to the to the artwork itself
the film I didn't want I completed it so
I I don't lose sight of that I agree
with what you're saying there is changes
coming and I i do think eventually the
younger generation going to a movie
theater is not going to be as magical as
it was for me they're just going to be
their magic is going to be watching it
on a 30 inch imac screen and i'll be
fine with that I've got no problem i'm
not like david lynch's like you know
watching a movie on a phone is horrible
hell i watch movies on my phone all the
time doesn't bother me at all but I
still want to make a movie I don't want
to make a 30 minute movie I don't want
to get 15 minute movie I make a movie i
love it i love that art form so you know
there's that